عارفين لما الواحد كده تجيله كثير تعليقات
على موضوع معين فيقرر انه يسبقهم ويعلق هو
على نفسه قبل ما اي احد ثاني كذا يعلق
يعني بالضبط هذا اللي عمله الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اللي يبدو ملم من الناس
وتعليقاتهم المستمره على صحته وقوى
العقليه وقرر هو ينكت على الموضوع
تصريح بايدنكا في المؤتمر السنوي للرابطه
الدوليه لرجال الاطفاء في واشنطن نتكلم
معاهم وشكرهم على انقاذ حياته في عام 1988
وكشف عن معلومات طبيه اول مره الناس
بتسمعها مثل اصابته بتمدد الاوعيه الدمويه
في الدماغ عام 88 واجراء عمليه جراحيه
لمعالجه التمدد وهناك نكت على الموضوع
وقال انه في العمليه فتحوا راسي كذا مره
علشان يشوفوا لو عندي مخ طبعا ما بيخفى
على احد الكلام عن صحه بايدن من اول يوم
تولى الرئاسه فهو اكبر الرئاسه سنا والان
مع اعلان ترشحوا لولايه ثانيه الكلام زاد
اكثر واكثر خاصه من معارضي اللي بيلعبوا
كثير على ورقه انه صحته مو تمام وبصراحه
حتى الان سجل بايدن كمان مو مساعدهم كثير
فمن كم يوم طبيب بايدن النشر مذكره لوسائل
الاعلام قال فيها انه في ورم سرطان يتشخص
في الرئيس في صدره وتم ازالته في 16
فبراير وحاول يطمن الناس انه ورم صغير ومو
من النوع اللي بينتشر بس يعني الناس مسكت
في الموضوع طبعا مع انه اطباء البيت
الابيض طلعوا تقرير من اسابيع عن قدي ايش
صحه الرئيس عظيمه وانه لائق صحيا غير
موضوع السرطان هذا في كمان تصريحات الرئيس
وزلات لسانه المتكرره واللي مخوفه معارضي
وفي كمان تعثروا سقوطه اكثر من مره وخصوصا
على سلالم الطائره ولعلمكم امس تعثر عليها
ثاني وهو ماشي يركب الطياره من الباما
[موسيقى]